there's a few things I would want to
know and Adam I'm going to say this and
then I'm going to come to so I think you
want to say something there's a few
things I want to know
you know the data that shows for every
conservative Professor there's 11 to 13
liberals in College University it's
great it's good for us to know that and
in the stat that says for every you know
out of a hundred teachers K through 12
in public schools 97 of them in English
English teachers 97 out of 100 teachers
gave to democratic party three gave to
Republican and he'd go to health
teachers K-12 it's 98 to 2 and then if
you do math and science it's 87 to 13
right where we know at least Math and
Science 87 are Democrats 13 no
Republicans conservatives great what
percentage of FBI as a whole would you
say are Democrats or Republicans or
independents
that that's a tough one to put as a
whole because there's some great
divisions within the FBI so there's
about 40 000 employees in the FBI only
14 000 are special agents so the
majority of the population is support
staff
um it's different culturally for support
staff I think they tend to lean and
especially in the intelligence analysis
field they tend to lean left those are
the people that are writing essentially
their profession is writing College term
papers and they're very over-educated
College mindset so that that and you've
seen like that Richmond field office a
radical traditional catholic memo came
out from an intelligence analyst
definitely only using left-wing sources
on that as far as the administrative
staff goes I never really dug into
politics with too many of them I think
from the the agent population then you
also have to split between the rank and
file boots on the ground guys that just
want to be cops and and they tend to be
moderate to conservative uh I think that
that's it's gun culture I mean you're
obviously the Second Amendment comes in
and that's going to be a good guide a
Plumb line for politics and if you're
comfortable carrying a gun you probably
support Second Amendment you're probably
conservative but the management
structure is left-leaning and I I
attribute that to the the way that that
process works it's very self-selecting
because in order to become a manager in
the FBI you have to be one to be willing
to go back and forth to Washington DC
all the time Family Roots aren't there
secondly you have to initiate something
that is new and novel do something with
a splash to put on your resume and the
nature of a conservative person is what
do I what's the waste Fraud and Abuse
that I can cut and just do the job sure
the person who's left-leaning is not
opposed to a new initiative and that's
where you know I made the comparison to
the uh the the movie Jurassic world
where Vincent d'onofrio's character
wants to use the Velociraptors to go
after terrorists and and it's funny but
it's it's true because it briefs well
you put it on a PowerPoint we don't need
a drone strike we've done that I can't
promote off a drone strike or send an
unseal team I'll use Velociraptors and
that's how somebody would promote within
the military and within the FBI is it a
similar structure like when you're in
the Bible if you're watching this and
you're enjoying and you want more you
want to hear more from what these
gentlemen have to say in a long-form
podcast where they can talk freely it's
about them today it's not about us but
if you give it a thumbs up subscribe to
the Channel and share it so other people
can see it as well we've grown quickly
to uh 10 000 people live watching it
right now
I think more and more people need to
hear what these gentlemen have to say in
the middle in the military you know how
uh hhc or headquarters would look at
field they would look at grunts like
you're you're dumb you just carry a gun
and I'm an officer my my boots are
always shine and clean look how dirty
your boots are you know I'm always I got
my stuff from you know Quartermasters I
got my crease everything you look like
you know dirt you don't look good you
don't do this there was a certain like
I'm smarter than you I'm better than you
and then when you would say yes sir to
enlisted they're like hey don't don't
tell me that I work for a living is is
it that kind of a mindset where the guys
at that level thing you guys are just
just listen go do the work but we're
gonna tell you what to do is it kind of
like that kind of a culture yeah okay
you know because I can I can speak to
the Army side of things too very similar
experience I had a couple really good
officers
um but by and large that type of hubris
it's it has infected the FBI at the
senior management levels
yeah that's a problem when that happens
because when it's a top-down and and the
guys are doing the work and by the way
you both worked under Comey and you
worked under Ray right I was just under
Ray you were just underrate okay so you
got involved what year when when 2018 I
got hired 2018. so he's 2017 August I
think is when he came in and right
before that was Comey for whatever four
years he was in how different was it was
there was there a immediate feel of a
different in culture under Comey array
or no you don't feel nothing it was the
same thing well I I didn't really feel
it I was in a small office
um but I do think that there was a
cultural change that happened and we
were talking about this actually earlier
um after September 11th when Bob Mueller
became the FBI director and the
transition to the intelligence agency
that you now see through its full
fruition began and the people that came
in uh under Mueller in the early days
they're now in a position of leadership
in the FBI so they came in it's a very
Patriot Act neocon mindset that maybe
inspired them to join then Comey comes
in and he brought in the I'm ethical
beyond all reproach and and unethical I
I am I'm the ethical and I I I think the
story is that the his lieutenants and
the folks that were around him and are
now ascending these very high levels
they were called the College of
cardinals because they are True
Believers in their utmost morality you
cannot question they've never sat looked
in the mirror and said am I the bad guy
and now they are the executive assistant
director what an arrogant way of doing
things oh my God that's disgusting I've
been around people like that I've never
met anybody that's you know there's
people like that in church there's
people like that in schools there's
people like that everywhere and they're
very annoying to work for and work with
and there's there's a big gap also in
their experience on on the ground with
people so take Jennifer Moore she's just
about to retire at the executive
assistant director uh she's been in the
FBI since the mid 90s she came in before
uh her time she was not an agent she was
a support staff and then eventually
became an agent she worked FBI cases
from 1999 to 2005. in a 30-year career
six of them were spent actually doing
the investigative work that she is now
having this managerial responsibility of
overseeing and I think that that just
leads to a tremendous disconnect between
the the management class and the rank
and file so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign